resserre pour des constructeurs
d'immeubles à logements,
frappés par l'explosion des
coûts des matériaux.
JERÔME THIBEAULT, cofond
- Quelqu'un qui achète
un terrain présentement,
avec les nouveaux coûts de
construction et les taux
c'est sûr que les chiffres ont
un peu moins de sens
qu'il faisait, il y a deux ans.
chantier 200 logements par année
termine la construction
d'un immeuble de 52 unités
locatives à Saint-Zotique
Les coûts du pr
inzaine de millions $
ont bondi de 20 % depuis
le début des travaux.
- Pour être sûr, sûr d'avoir
un sous-traitant qui va être là
lorsqu'on va avoir besoin de
200 000 $ de plus.
- Les exemples s'enchaînent.
- Ce fil là ici, je peux vousmoa
augmenté de 280 %.
- Les deux propriétaires ont dû
hausser rs de 8 à 10 %
par rapport aux prévisions
initiales.copropriétaire Groupea
- On veut faire attention.
On ne peut pas juste augmenter
les loyers parce que les coûts
de construction augmentent.
gagner, ils se sont tournés vers
un tout ogramme
d'assurance-prêt de la Société
canadienne d'hypothèques et de
APH Select permet d'étirer
l'amortissement jusqu'à 50 ansas
et de payer une prime réduite, à
condition d'offrir des unités
abordabl sur le pl sur le pl sun
énergétique. Firma est en
attente d'approbation. Neuf
logements seront offerts à 30 %,
donc abordables.
- Il aurait fallu
dèle d'affaire,
peut-être ralentir la quantitédà
construire dans les prochaines
années. Il aurait fallutre repos
projets.
- ... Pas le scénario idéal
alors qu'il manquelogements au .
- Game changer dans l'industrie.
- La SCHL espère ainsi pouvoir
s abordables,
malgré la conjoncture.MICHEL MAe
compte, institutions financières
- Je vous dirais qu'il y a déjà
demandes qui sont entrées.
- Les coûts de co
n'épargnent pas le logement
social non plus.Et les 70 000 $s
dans le dernier budget du Québec
pour compléter 3500 unités
seraient insuffisants.
JEAN-FRANCOIS GILK
organismson quartier
- À un moment donné, il y aura
une quadrature de cercle qui va
assez dramatiques.
- Rien n'indique que les pri
des matériaux sont sur le point,
tant au privé qu'au public,
demeure vigoureuse.
Ici Mathieu Dion,-Canada, M